there's a lot of people Americans born
and raised Americans and big powerful
positions all throughout our country
that dream of the day where America is
no longer a stand-alone independent
entity they want to see one world money
one world Military One World Medicine
one world everything and you can't have
one world anything as long as the United
States is still standing on both feet
and able to hold its own so if you can
disincentivize kids brainwash them and
grow them up into a young adult of
military age that is not willing to
fight for their country they don't think
their country is worth fighting for
guess what they won't fight for their
country and they won't be too upset if
somebody wants to come in here and take
the place over or take it down